er war Auftragskiller der russischen
Unterwelt und verbrachte drei Jahre im
Gefängnis marad gaviolin hatte einen
mafia-chef getötet nach dem Knast nahm
er einen Job als Söldner an das war 2015
sein Weg führte in ein militärisches
Trainingslager nach südostland
nicht die Armee war und alles irgendwie
mit unseren Gesetzen so gar nicht
zusammenpasst
Geld war natürlich wichtig wir wurden
gut bezahlt nach russischem Maßstab
schon bei der Ankunft im Lager gab es 80
Euro und wenn es zum Einsatz kam dann
120 bis 150 Euro am Tag
der Name der Söldnertruppe für die
gabidolin von da ankämpfte Gruppe Wagner
[Musik]
das hier sind die typischen Orden der
Gruppe Wagner die schwarzen Kreuze das
hier ist für den Sieg über den is
und das hier ist meine Erkennungsmarke
die Gruppe Wagner in Propaganda-Videos
inszeniert sie sich als Kampf erprobt in
Krisenregionen auf der ganzen Welt
ihr Gründer Dimitri utkin ein ehemaliger
russischer Geheimdienst Offizier seine
Gesinnung auf dem Körper tätowiert SS
Runen der Neonazi hat offenbar beste
Kontakte zum Herrscher im Gremmel
Präsident Wladimir Putin ließ sich
zusammen mit Dimitri utkin ablichten
und bei einem Empfang des Kremls am 9
dezember 2016 war
utkin auch unter den geladenen Gästen
utkin führt seine Truppe offiziell als
private Sicherheitsunternehmen doch die
Gruppe Wagner gilt als Schattenarmee
Putins und dafür gibt es Belege
gegründet wurde sie 2014 im Don Bass in
der Ostukraine genau zu der Zeit als
prorussisches Separatisten einen
Bürgerkrieg mit der Ukraine begannen
diese Filmaufnahmen aus dem Winter 2015
zeigen Wagner Söldner im Einsatz im
Kampf gegen die Ukraine
dies ist der vierte Tag unseres
Einsatzes wir werden gerade mit Granaten
beschossen
der ukrainische Geheimdienst sammelte
Informationen über die Gruppe Wagner
identifizierte rund 4.200 Söldner mit
Namen Geburtsdatum militärischem Rang
Auszeichnungen und persönlichen Fotos
Söldner kosten viel Geld nach
Erkenntnissen europäischer
Sicherheitsbehörden finanziert Jewgeni
prigoschin die Schattenarmee er ist
russischer Oligarch und vertrauter
Putins
zu Sowjet Zeiten saß er neun Jahre im
Gefängnis in den 2000er Jahren stieg
prigoshi in die Gastronomie ein und
verdiente ein Vermögen in dem er
Moskauer Schulen und die russische Armee
mit Essen versorgte
später bewirtete er Putin und seine
Staatsgäste und galt als Putins Koch
Einsätze der Gruppe Wagner sind neben
der Ukraine in Madagaskar Mosambik Sudan
in der Zentralafrikanischen Republik in
Syrien und in Libyen belegt
in Syrien kämpften russische Wagner
Söldner zunächst gemeinsam mit der
syrischen Armee gegen den islamischen
Staat wie hier in Palmyra 2017 auch
marath gabi duulin ist dabei ihr Auftrag
den syrischen Diktator Assad Stützen
russische Einflusszonen im Nahen Osten
sichern
kann diese Truppe irgendetwas ohne die
Zustimmung der Regierung tun
das kann sie nicht auf keinen Fall sie
bekommt ihre gesamte Ausrüstung von der
Regierung viele Rekruten sind
Reservisten der Armee das
Verteidigungsministerium stellt den
Transport und die Logistik um sie an die
Orte der Kampfhandlungen zu bringen
es ist definitiv ein Zweig der Regierung
eine Einrichtung des Staates
2018 erhalten gabidolin und seine
wagnertruppe eine neue Mission ein Öl
und Gas fällt erobern und sichern in der
Nacht zum 8 februar 2018 starten die
Wagner Sölden eine Offensive doch das
Ölfeld ist unter Kontrolle der Kurden
und die werden von den USA militärisch
unterstützt die russischen Söldner
scheitern
200 sterben durch US-Bomben
kamen herunter und gingen direkt neben
mir hoch mein ganzes Gesicht war mit
Brandwunden übersät
schwer unbeschreiblich wenn du glaubst
dass du stirbst du liegst einfach nur
auf dem Boden und wartest dass es
aufhört mehr kannst du nicht tun
einer der 200 Wagner Söldner die im
Bombenhagel starben
er hinterlässt Frau und Kind vom Staat
bekam seine Familie eine Sterbeurkunde
sonst nichts
der Einsatz von Söldnern ermöglicht es
dem Kreml Zahlungen an Hinterbliebene zu
vermeiden und die Zahl der getöteten
russischen Soldaten zu vertuschen
empfinde ich für unser Land Schande
unseren Präsidenten dass er so etwas
geschehen lässt
[Musik]
ein Video aus dem juni 2017 auch aus
Syrien weil es kaum vorstellbare
Grausamkeiten zeigt veröffentlichen wir
nur Standbilder ein Deserteur der
syrischen Armee wird gefoltert ermordet
und verbrannt die Täter russische
Söldner der Gruppe Wagner einer der
Folterer wurde identifiziert Stanislav
ditschko
ich glaube nicht dass es eine Ausnahme
war und darin besteht die Gefährlichkeit
dieser unkontrollierten bewaffneten
Kräfte nicht umsonst gibt es in der
zivilisierten Welt ein Gewaltmonopol des
Staates doch diese Männer agieren völlig
außerhalb des Gesetzes wer kommandiert
sie wer schulgur der russische
Verteidigungsminister du hast ein
Sprecher sagt nananana das sind wir
nicht
Menschenrechtsorganisationen werfen der
russischen Söldnertruppe Gewalt gegen
Zivilisten Folter und Mord vor nicht nur
in Syrien auch in der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik und den
Libyen
als Vorwürfe öffentlich werden Fragen
Journalisten nach als im Januar 2020 die
deutsche Kanzlerin Putin in Moskau
besucht wie viele russische Söldner
halten so Wagner Söldner halten sich in
Libyen auf
russische Staatsbürger gibt dann
vertreten sie nicht die Interessen des
russischen Staates und sie bekommen auch
kein Geld vom russischen Stadt
der russische militäranalyst Russland le
view hat andere Erkenntnisse zur Gruppe
Wagner
wichtig war dass wir herausfanden ihr
Hauptstützpunkt befindet sich in molkino
in Südrußland auf dem Stützpunkt der
zehnten Brigade an der Spezialeinheit
der russischen Armee so wurde klar dass
dies keine private unabhängige Truppe
eines privaten Oligarchen ist sondern
eine geheime Abteilung der russischen
Regierung und des
Verteidigungsministeriums
gegen den Chef der wagnertruppe Dimitri
utkin und den Geldgeber Jewgeni
prigorcin hatte die EU im dezember 2021
Sanktionen verhängt gestoppt hat das
Putins Schattenarmee offenbar nicht der
britische Geheimdienst meldet in der
Ostukraine sollen rund 1.000 Söldner der
Gruppe Wagner Kämpfen auf Seiten der
russischen Streitkräfte